de toi car
[Musique]
elle éclate il avait d'ailleurs j'ai pas
encore vu ça alors qu'arte ça fait du
bien vous de dire du mal de guillaume
que c'est impossible
un truc un petit truc impossible un
petit truc médiatique ya bien un truc
négatif vidéo il est très bordélique
ah ça me rendait dingue ah ben voilà pas
du tout bordélique
c'est vrai mais la truite la truck les
choses la truite pour brawn hommage
voilà au moment m biechlin aïda schloss
il faut à elle dit là où nichent forêt
l'euphorie des rails jusqu'à 1m
d'ingolstadt hounds hines ussery danser
un mini-show corée l'euphorie berwyn
filezilla aux niches forel fort ubm
pagis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pour toi sur dish mind
chat
mme aïcha par l'allemand ça veut dire
quoi ça va m'aider trésor les
corrections de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus